At the beginning of this lesson we learned that
there are four major ABO blood groups. We have blood
group A, B, AB, and O. Now, we saw the
breakdown of these blood type groups in the US population.
What's really intriguing is that this describes what we see
on the surface of the red blood cells. When you
go to the clinic they'll tell you "What's on your
blood cell? Do you have A type, B type, A
and B on your cell, or no type at all, O type. But you have two alleles for the
ABO gene, two possibilities. You could be two A's or two B's or an A and a
B or maybe you're an A and an O.
Right? And depending on those combinations together that will
result in which blood type you are. I want
you to tell me what the possible allele combinations
are for each of these different blood type groups. I'll
help you out with the first one to give you
an example. To be blood type A we could have
AA alleles. Or, we could have an A allele and an
O allele, because the O allele wouldn't produce anything, right.
We get nothing. But the A allele would put the
A antigen with the A carbohydrate, on the surface of
our red blood cells, because the A allele codes for the
ABO protein. That will make and put the
A carbohydrate on the surface of red blood cells.
So these are the only two possible allele combinations
we could have. I want you to fill that
in for these other 3 options here. And see
if you can come up with the correct allele
combinations. Separate each combination with a comma, and also
remember that the order of the alleles doesn't matter.